How to become the British monarch:
Historically, the crown was on your head normally because you have the largest army. When
My older ones, my elder, continued with the control of the army and therefore the crown was relocated
to his head, although, of course, someone with a larger army could change the political landscape
quite abruptly
As time went by and the world was less violent in the end in 1701 parliament settled down
A set of rules to transfer the crown from one head to the other - fortunately, with less
agitation than previously.
That's how the rules of 1701 worked:
First: not being a Catholic.
The British monarch is also the head of the Anglican Church, to which the monarch must
convert if you are not a member yet. Except that if you are a Catholic, there is no crown for you.
The history of the royal family and how this norm was created is a story for another time,
but it is enough to say that the dimplacia of the greater army was involved.
And, by the way, you can not skip this norm by turning yourself from Catholicism to
something different and then to Anglicanism. In the eyes of the crown, Catholicism is transitive.
Second: do not be a bastard
Sometimes it's good to be the king, but it's never good to be an illegitimate son
of the king - who is out of the queue for the crown literally at the time of his conception.
If you are related to the monarch but you are a Catholic or a bastard or both, the crown
He has the beautiful term 'Death by nature' to refer to you and your lack of right to succession.
Third: the spouses do not count.
While people often think of kings and queens as a couple: it's not how it works here.
The wives of the monarch are called royal consorts. Maybe they're called "prince" or "queen," though
As for the crown, they are not in the line of the throne, they are only
the 23 chromosomes necessary for the creation of the royal heir.
Fourth and Last: male progenitor.
These are the inheritance algorithm. When the monarch dies, or abdicates, but usually
dies, the crown goes to the older child than "death by nature". If there is
a big sister, bad luck for her: the child stays the crown.
It's pretty simple, but there are cases that are not obvious: take a king with two children: if the greatest
He dies before the king, obviously the crown goes to his youngest son (who is now the eldest).
But what if the older son had given a grandson to the king before he died? Where is the crown going?
then?
Well, the crown basically makes you see that everyone (except "dead by nature) is alive:
After the king's death the crown goes to the eldest son, who is like the king,
but he is dead, therefore the norm goes back to work, and the crown goes
to his * son, and NO, as it would seem obvious, to his brother.
But if this rule of 1701 says that older children get the crown, how has it been
queens? Basically, the daughters were the last choice, and this explains why there has been
so few
To get the crown, the daughter had to be the only daughter of the monarch or the eldest daughter
without brothers
Pregnant mothers should have put their daughters a little nervous with real aspirations.
Branches of family trees sometimes die: either by war, pestilence or anything else
And the contingency plan of the crown if it reaches a deadlock is to raise the level, and then
Apply the rules again to find a living boss to be over. If there is no luck,
up again, and repeat and repeat until you find the royal heir.
There will always be an heir. The first king of England is for over a thousand years
And the mates of human reproduction confined by DNA tests reveal that
Every European living is distantly related to it. Therefore the crown will find
the way
From the first king to the new millennium, the rules went well, making monarchs,
although with a sexist result, for which nobody seemed upset until,
In 2013 for any reason in particular, everyone decided that the rules should be updated
*Right Now*.
The parliament and the monarchy gathered and did some cavis: in particular
eliminating the masculine part of the norm no. 4
As of 2013, the crown sees all royal sons and daughters equally. The only one
What matters is the order of birth.
Before 2013, the boy between two twins in development could relax
sure that the crown would be yours regardless of what happened on the delivery day, but on
The 2013 egalitarian world is a race for the "door" to get the crown.